I don't know if I have ever met two
people who are more suited to each other
than you two to Berrien ours
mr. feels different Rena tiny futures
changed I saw that the tart where are
you Hey look at me this is not going to
happen I swear when both my parents
lives I will protect you we need to
figure out everything that happens
leading up to Irishness death when I saw
the future there is a new scroll with
the change one of an event you can
change them all my future isn't the only
one that we need to change I'm afraid
time will wake up be her reading reply
will drive you back to the future
I said you out here because you're a
hero I are asleep hero right now I we
can prove that we can also the future
here in them and concentrate on the
exact date in the future that you
trusted too
hey youtubers it's Charlie so still no
facecam just because this footage
dropped so quickly I cut myself shaving
this morning so just no face cam till
tomorrow probably there is an injustice
to giveaway that just started for a copy
of the game so that's going to alternate
with the reverse flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a flash related comment
on this video winners are announced at
the end be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
but this just gives you a little more
story in context for why Barry wants to
go back to the future they're all
hanging out in Barry and irises new
apartment that they teased at the end of
episode 9 in Barry and iris living
together you can see that they're
totally getting it on so if you enjoy
that there's going to be a little bit of
that and you have the killer frost stuff
where they want to try and change her
future - so this is all Back to the
Future in the name of changing
everyone's destiny but as we've learned
from the reverse-flash
anytime you try to change time to try to
avoid some big catastrophic event time
finds a way to replace that so there are
fixed points in time and then there are
things that you can change but the
problem is is that it's not always clear
what you can change and there's actually
some really cool upgrades that YouTube
is giving me they'll all explain at the
end of the video - so the real danger
here is in Cisco vibing them back to the
future very trying to change all the
things that he does that might lead to
that actually end up leading to that so
self-fulfilling prophecy they did say
that Barry was going to get crazier and
crazier with the things that he tries to
do to try to avoid irises future so it
makes it sound like they're going to go
back to that moment more than what this
episode will probably answer that
question the most like they'll probably
be very reluctant to go back to that
usually iris is the voice of reason but
she's freaking out here - in the Time
Vault so we're back to the Future
newspaper he was showing Oliver this
during the big crossover episode but
what we might see is just like during
season 1 when time changed just a little
bit the reverse flash kept checking the
newspaper to see how things had changed
so they were like little minor edits
that happen
so we just have to keep
every time he looked at this newspaper
again but I think the idea here that
they're kind of teasing is that no
matter what Barry does this is always
going to happen so he's gonna have to
find some other solution they announced
that the black flash is coming back in
the back half of the season they didn't
say when they didn't say what he's going
to be doing but that might have
something to do with this avatar plot
because sabotager speedster
the black flash means the death of one
of the speedsters they already might try
to repeat the big twist of the season
two finale when he used the time race to
get zoom but for those that are
wondering like how fast Barry got like
if zoom was supposed to be the fastest
you remember that he was losing speed
Barry was getting faster and faster
Barry himself is actually like a battery
for the Speed Force so he can be as fast
as he wants he can manifest any powers
that he wants but just like a video game
he has to sort of unlock those abilities
with experience and the adventures that
he has so sometimes like if time changes
those can get rolled back or his big
weakness you know like big heroes tend
to have big weaknesses is iris so that's
going to cause him to make all kinds of
crazy decisions and then you have the
Wally storyline which is kind of a
separate thing but they're looping it
back around so like he's learning to be
the flash he needs a mentor like Barry
but because Barry's freaking out about
iris he's doing a terrible job so in the
episode like the whole thing is them
capturing plunder who's one of the
Rogues from Geoff Johns air in the
comics he was part of that future news
broadcast
so Barry sees him and thinks oh my god
if we capture him it might lead to this
future event so he's a little gun-shy
Wally steps in steps into the limelight
a little bit and that causes some of the
tension that we've seen in the other
Clips like this Wally congratulations
that was amazing
great job well into flash let them know
that's how it's done we just supposed to
plunder in iron Heights
again his real name is Jared Murillo
turns out he's wanted for a string of
robberies from here to Star City well
what was I supposed to be shadowing me
wait you're mad at me I thought observe
and learn that's it well that did bear
ease up while I just saved your life
I'm sorry Wally but if you can't learn
to follow orders this deal between us is
over okay Eddie fall man if you didn't
know this is coming back next week all
the DC shows are coming back next week
legends of tomorrow is moving to Tuesday
nights what's probably going to happen
is this is going to be my tentative
video schedule now like it just depends
on what ends up happening on those days
if something really big like this
morning the injustice trailer dropped so
I felt like I had to do a video for that
things will always adjust just a little
bit according to what ends up happening
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see the videos
upload you get everything just fine but
you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook I usually post updates there is
awesome emergency on Twitter in its
emergency awesome on Facebook but
there's so much huge stuff happening in
the back half of the season we have our
gorilla grodd two-part episode we're
going to meet other versions of the
flash from the multiverse people that we
haven't seen in a while or going to come
back like I just did a video about Eddie
coming back so there's so much happening
really like the black flash is probably
the thing I'm most excited about but
this is all about Barry versus savat are
just these first couple of episodes is
him trying to change the future so we
got to figure out what they're going to
do about killer frost how they're going
to prevent her from turning against the
team and going off on our own and
keeping iris alive and well till season
4 so whether or not Barry figures it out
the temporary band-aid is to actually
stash iris inside the Speed Force Grant
Gustin posted this picture that was
completely green-screen the heading here
reads that it's from episode 13 so it's
not for a while but it makes it sound
like he's going to be going into the
Speed Force or something really crazy is
going to happen where they have to
include a whole bunch of special effects
so like whatever it is it's going to be
pretty crazy but like Jay Garrick has
explained the mythology as a Speed Force
a little bit we're going to push deeper
into that so you
be seeing new flash power he teased the
news suit so there's going to be all
kinds of upgrades happening I can't wait
to see it so if you have any requests
for flash bonus videos in the next
couple days just leave them in the
comments if you want me to explain any
concepts or anything in particular but
they'll probably be some more arrow
footage tomorrow so I'll post that I
know there's a lot of Prometheus
questions but I'll say congratulations
to the first injustice giveaway winner
set easily please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details so there's a new
round that started in this video on
ounce the winner the next time I post a
DC video just explain those YouTube
upgrades YouTube is giving me some new
features that'll help me communicate
with you guys when there's not a video
to post so like a lot of times it's
harder for me to communicate what the
schedule is how things are changing if
something happens if I don't post a new
video because a lot of you don't follow
me on Twitter and Facebook the one you
can fix that now but there's also like a
new section on my youtube channel that
they're going to give me with some new
features it'll happen this spring
they're also going to be fixing alerts
too so that it'll be a lot easier for
you guys to get videos without getting
bogged down with like thousands and
thousands of comments so all that stuff
will be happening in the next couple of
months so we got a lot of awesome flash
stuff coming a lot of awesome movie
stuff from DC and Marvel and a lot of
cool YouTube stuff that's happening
where you guys wait for that next video
you can click here to re-watch the
injustice 2 gameplay footage all that
trailer and you can click here for the
next legends of tomorrow trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video